Professor Amy
Hungerford: It is the
seventh week of term,
and in this class,
if you have kept up,
you have read nine novels in
seven weeks.
So, if you kept up,
I want you, right now,
to pat yourself on the back.
Oh, I don't see a lot of
patting.
Okay: if you just missed one
novel.
Okay.
I don't want to look.
Do your patting later.
Let me say that you have broken
the back of the course,
not to use too violent a
metaphor.
It's the seventh week.
We have six weeks left.
In those six weeks we have
five--count them--five novels.
That's it, and one of them you
get to choose.
So, instead of doing two novels
in a week, you'll have a week
and a half for one novel.
This is a much more humane pace.
Why are you laughing?
It's not funny.
You also, of course,
have Spring Break.
If you use Spring Break wisely,
read, in a somewhat leisurely
way, in Myrtle Beach,
as you're relaxing on the
beach, Blood
Meridian--excellent beach
novel--you'll be in great shape.
You'll be riding high through
the rest of the term,
easy-peasy, okay.
Why did I do that to you these
last three weeks?
Why did I do that?
Well, one reason,
as I said at the beginning of
class, at the beginning of the
term, is that I did not want you
to be crushed after Spring
Break.
I wanted you to be crushed now,
so it'll be better later.
But there's another reason.
So, why didn't I just drop
one of those novels?
Well, my lecture today is,
in part, an answer to that
question.
A syllabus is not a parade.
It's not a succession of novels
that passes by,
and we wave,
and we catch whatever candy or
beads they throw at us,
and then we go home at the end
of the day with sore feet from
standing too long.
It's not like that.
A syllabus, at least in this
kind of class and with me
teaching it, is an argument.
It's an argument about a whole
historical period.
It's an argument about a chunk
of literary-historical history.
It's an argument about the
evolution of an art form in a
particular place and time.
In order to preserve that
quality of a syllabus,
you have to read quite a bit.
Reading quite a bit means that
you can begin to see the
lineaments of larger trends and
movements in that historical
period.
It allows you to amass enough
evidence to build an
intellectual understanding of
what's going on in this period.
If I had dropped a novel,
there are certain kinds of
arguments I would not have been
able to make,
and the argument that I'm going
to make for you today would not
be as compelling as I hope it
will be.
So, as in the Franny and
Zooey lecture,
I tried to demonstrate for you
in a very self-conscious way how
literary scholars make local
arguments that take into account
an entire novel,
its major features,
and use the evidence of detail
at the level of text to support
those kinds of claims.
Today I'm going to make a much
broader argument of the kind
that literary scholars are often
interested in making.
I'm going to make an argument
about a major trend in this
period, and to do that I will
use evidence,
and I'm going to call on you to
help me put together the
evidence for broader claims that
cross novels.
An argument of this kind has a
different quality from those
more local arguments about
individual novels that I've made
each week.
It's different in the sense
that I want, and most literary
scholars want,
such arguments not to be
totally counterintuitive in the
way that you can sometimes take
pleasure in making a reading of
a local novel counterintuitive.
For the big arguments,
you want to be able to account
for what is obvious about the
period,
but perhaps has not been
justified as an analysis of the
period.
So, you want a sense of
inevitability,
that this argument you're
making explains all kinds of
things that people have always
noticed about that period.
In the same way that,
when I lectured on Franny
and Zooey, I asked you what
was obvious to you about the
novel and then my argument went
around and spoke back to those
things at different points.
So this general argument aims
to speak to those obvious parts,
but it speaks more
strongly to those obvious
perceptions,
and so I'm launching into a
different kind of argument.
What I want to talk to you
about today is a particular
narrative form and convention,
and I'm calling it the Identity
Plot.
Certainly, I am not the first
scholar to think about identity
as a form of narrative in this
period,
and it's precisely because I am
not the first that I can give it
this sort of name.
There is so much work that's
been done excavating how
identity works in the novel in
this period that it has become
something we know a lot about.
What hasn't been said before is
that it has this particular
name, and I use this name
because,
for me, the Identity Plot,
which I will explain in a few
moments, fulfills much the same
function in fiction of this
period as the Marriage Plot did
for the Victorian novel.
So, any of you who have taken
the Victorian novel class,
Professor Yeazell's course,
or have studied or just read a
lot of Jane Austen novels,
Dickens novels and so on,
you will know what the Marriage
Plot is.
The Marriage Plot is that
engine of storytelling that
makes novels hang on a structure
of a couple and the question of
whether they will get together
or not.
Now, there are all kinds of
stages in that development,
the development of that
narrative.
Are the couples from the same
social class?
Are they from geographically
contiguous places?
Do they have personalities that
match?
Do their parents agree?
Are they related to each other
secretly (always a problem)?
There are all kinds of things
that can go wrong for a couple
trying to get together,
and the Victorian novel was
very good at generating
narrative from all those kinds
of complications.
Then, there are different kinds
of outcomes that you can have in
the novel governed by the
Marriage Plot.
One is the comedy.
That's when you get married at
the end, the couple gets
married.
Then there's the tragedy:
They don't, and they should
have, and we all know it.
So, Pride and Prejudice
would be an example of the
former kind;
Anna Karenina perhaps an
example of the latter kind,
even though that's a novel
really about adultery.
It totally depends on the
conventions of the Marriage
Plot.
The Identity Plot works in much
the same way.So,
what is the Identity Plot?
I am going to give you an
unusual sight in my class now,
and that is Power Point.
I think I'm sort of surprised
and delighted by this myself,
so we'll see how it works.
So, if you're taking notes,
which I encourage you to do,
you will find there are bolded
words that you can copy down.
The Identity Plot:
Narrative Form in Post-1945
Fiction.
Isn't that snazzy?
Okay.
(Oops.
I've already made my first
technological mistake.
There we go.) Six elements of
the Identity Plot.
Make sure you capitalize
"Identity" and "Plot," please,
and also give me credit in the
footnote of your notes for that
phrase.
The narrative of the Identity
Plot novel revolves around the
question of how to define and
understand a character's
identity (big surprise there).
And, number 2:
the character needs to be a
member of the minority within a
larger society.
I am not going to ask you to
volunteer examples of these,
because it's just too obvious
that our last three or four
novels each feature one of these
characteristics,
or all of them.
The third one is absolutely
crucial to the development of
the Identity Plot,
and that is that the character
is also at odds with the
minority group of which he or
she is a part.
This is important,
because without it,
the Identity Plot gets really
boring.
It doesn't have a lot of
complication.
If all you have to do is
realize, as you're going about
your life, "wow,
I am a member of X or Y group.
Great.
I know who I am now.
Done."
that is a really short story,
actually, and it's not a good
short story, either.
There is just not enough
resistance to the evolution of
the plot, so it's really
important.
The drama of the Identity
Plot depends upon this.
Furthermore,
the character in question needs
to be conflicted about his or
her difference from the majority
and about his or her
difference from the minority
group.
Can anyone think of an example
of this?
Can anyone think of an example?
Yes, Eli.Student:
Woman
Warrior.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Absolutely,
yeah.
So in case you didn't hear Eli,
Woman Warrior is a great
example of this.
Maxine (that's what I'll call
her when I'm talking about the
character Maxine Hong
Kingston) Maxine feels alienated
from Chinese culture because of
the misogyny she perceives in
that culture,
but she also turns to Chinese
culture as a way to identify
herself and to give her a
positive self-image,
as in that story of the woman
warrior (which I actually didn't
ask you to read,
but there are other examples in
the stories that I did ask you
to read, chapters that I did ask
you to read,
to give her that sense of
grounding as a person).
Other examples.
How about in The Bluest Eye?
Yes.
Student:
Franny and
Zooey.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Yeah.
I think Franny and Zooey
really does fit this model.
Yes.
There are lots of different
ways of conceiving what it means
to have a minority group at work
in these novels,
and I think Franny and Zooey
definitely imagines a
minority group as the Glass
family.
They're big enough to be a
group.
There are lots of children,
so you get that sense that
they're a clan;
they're sort of a tribe of
themselves.
They have this peculiar
quality, their intellectual sort
of complexity,
and also their artistic gifts,
especially their gifts in
language.
And there is a conflict between
Franny and Zooey,
and Zooey is really held out as
the custodian of the Glass
family identity,
so it's he who instructs Franny
and brings her finally back in
to the fold,
and that's an example of the
comic ending.
Other examples from other
novels.
Can anyone do this for
Bluest Eye?
How might Pecola be an
example of this?
Okay.
Let me do it.
Pecola goes up to the whores'
apartment and finds there a kind
of love and acceptance from
those women that does not judge
her for her ugliness,
that surrounds her with a rich
verbal culture as well as a
culture of affection.
It is a group that has seceded
from the black community itself
but still maintains a certain
tie.
Remember the prostitutes'
admiration for the good
Christian woman.
That ties them to the
prevailing norms of the black
community.
So, Pecola finds an ideal black
community within that small
apartment, but she is alienated
from that positive black
self-image that she sees in
those women by her desire to
identify with white beauty,
to have blue eyes,
and so that's how she would
embody this.
Frieda is also an example of
this, Frieda and Claudia.
So, actually,
if we take the example of
Claudia, Claudia wants to be
like, remember the girl they
called Meringue Pie,
the light-skinned girl?
She wants to be like her,
but at the same time she
recognizes a certain insipid
quality to this girl.
She doesn't have the kind of
strength that Claudia and
Frieda, with the addition of
Pecola,
have as a little group that
doesn't pass judgment on their
own blackness.
So that, again,
between Claudia,
Frieda and Pecola there is
another small idealized black
community,
but Claudia is somewhat
conflicted, both about her
membership in that little group,
and her difference from the
influx of white blood into that
community, and white aesthetic
into that community.
So, she echoes,
in a less dramatic way,
the same kinds of conflicts
that you see in Pecola.
The fourth quality of the
Identity Plot is that
authenticity and origin are
always at stake in the
character's quest for personal
identity,
even when those things are
absent.
So, in the Woman
Warrior, we have an
excellent example of this,
in the beginning of the last
chapter that I asked you to
read, after she tells the whole
story of Moon Orchid and Brave
Orchid going to find Moon
Orchid's Chinese husband and
confronting him with Moon
Orchid's status as the first
wife.
After you get this whole richly
imagined story full of dialog,
the next chapter begins:
What my brother actually
said was "I drove Mom and second
Aunt to Los Angeles to see
Aunt's husband who got the other
wife."
"Did she hit him?
What did she say?
What did he say?"
"Nothing much.
Mom did all the talking."
"What did she say?"
"She said he'd better take them
to lunch at least."
"Which wife did he sit next to?
What did they eat?"
"I didn't go.
The other wife didn't either.
He motioned not to tell."
"I would have told.
If I was his wife I would have
told.
I would have gone to lunch and
kept my ears open."
"Oh, you know they don't talk
when they eat."
"What else did Mom say?"
"I don't remember.
I pretended a pedestrian broke
her leg so he would come."
"There must have been more.
Didn't Aunt get in one nasty
word?
She must have said something."
"No.
I don't think she said anything.
I don't remember her saying one
thing."
In fact, it wasn't me my
brother told about going to Los
Angeles.
One of my sisters told me what
he had told her.
The layers of inauthenticity in
the origin of this story are
deep.
There is no sense that the
story we have just been told in
great detail has any basis in
fact,
and yet this is a book that is
patently autobiographical.
It plays up the inauthenticity
and the unreliability of this
voice.
We know that we cannot trust
the details of what is given to
us, and yet the narrative tries
to seduce us with them,
tries to persuade us by their
very dramatic quality,
and their detail,
and by the way these stories
embody the voices of their
characters,
that these are real stories.
So, the voice in Kingston that
purports to be a source of
identity formation--she's going
to write herself into being--is
an inauthentic voice.
Now there was a controversy
about Maxine Hong Kingston.
Actually, it's been going on
for many decades.
It goes on today.
There is a scholar of Chinese
American literature named Frank
Chin.
He's also a novelist himself.
He has accused Kingston and a
few other writers,
in the starkest terms,
of being fakes and of being
against Chinese culture and of
being puppets of white culture.
Kingston's use of Chinese
literature has come under
particular attack from Chin,
and this happened in one of its
incarnations or one of its
iterations of this feud between
the two.
It actually happened at a
conference, face to face,
and I know you must think that
academic conferences are always
a thrill a minute.
It's not really usual that they
are, but I guess in this case it
was.
So, Frank Chin,
I guess, shouted her off the
stage.
I don't know all the details,
but it was very exciting,
I'm sure.
Nevertheless,
the argument is serious.
It's an argument about
authenticity,
the authenticity of Kingston's
use of Chinese literature.
So, imagine someone saying to
John Barth, "Wait a minute.
You changed the story of The
Odyssey.
You're a fake."
That's essentially what Frank
Chin says to Maxine Hong
Kingston.
It has a kind of traction to a
certain audience,
because the purity of an origin
of that kind matters,
if you think that that's where
authenticity of an identity
resides.
So, if it's a cultural
identity at stake,
the authenticity seems to
matter in a different way.
Now, Barth can give us a
different kind of example of
this.
Authenticity:
Is Menelaus' voice in The
Menelaiad really his own?
Is there some being left over
that's apart from that voice?
He says, "My voice diddles on."
Well, who's the "my"?
Is he just reducible to that
voice?
Is he Proteus?
Is Proteus him?
Has his identity been lost in
his wrestling with that changing
god?
The question of authenticity
haunts Menelaus.
It haunts Ambrose when he is in
the throes of passion and he
feels alienated from himself.
"This is passion.
I am experiencing it."
That's a kind of inauthenticity.
He can't be grounded in the
origin of identity that we think
of as the body.
So, a lot of these novels make
a problem out of authenticity.
When it doesn't seem like a
problem, a novel is making a
certain kind of claim about
identity right off the bat,
and that's that authenticity
doesn't matter.
But in the context of the
Identity Plot you know that it's
on the radar screen even if it
isn't something that is in the
novel itself;
it's there by its negative.
Finally,
there are comic versions and
tragic versions of the Identity
Plot, just as there are of the
Marriage Plot.
So, the comic version gives us
characters that come to peace
with their identity.
My favorite example of this is
actually a novel we're not
reading in this course,
although I could have added it,
couldn't I?
I could have done ten novels in
the first seven weeks.
I won't ask you to read it.
It's Barbara Kingsolver's
Pigs in Heaven.
In this novel,
this is the most extreme
example I know.
I can't remember the full
details, now,
but in that novel there is a
native American woman.
There is a native American
child who's adopted,
forcibly, in the forcible
adoptions, by a white family.
I think this is how the story
goes.
And, eventually,
after the Indian family tries
to get that child back,
it is discovered that the
adoptive mother was,
in fact, a member of that tribe
by a very diluted blood line.
And the adoptive mother marries
the child's full-blood
grandfather: perfect,
perfect comic ending for an
Identity Plot novel.
I would say that The Bluest
Eye is our tragic version of
this, where Pecola will never be
at peace.
She is in fact deranged by her
conflicted relationship to
identity.
Now, here is where we need
a distinction between literary
fiction and genre fiction.
Now, I could get in to lots of
trouble for these claims.
They're fairly broad,
and ideally I would want to
give them more nuance,
but I think it's useful to
think about this distinction.
Incarnations of these kinds of
narrative conventions that we
think of as literary use those
structures of narrative as
something to play off of or
something to inhabit while they
do a whole bunch of other
things.
Think of the ways that Humbert
and Nabokov use the conventions
of Romantic language to make us
believe that Humbert really
loves Lolita.
There is something operatic
about the extremity of the
situation we're given,
the extremity of the use of
those conventions in Lolita.
Well, in this case some of
our Identity Plot novels use
that plot to say something about
language, about literary
history, about tradition.
Some of them simply give us
aesthetic pleasure,
like the pleasure that we can
get from watching Barth use
words, make them funny,
be clever with them.
So, they may deliver an
artistic satisfaction that has
nothing to do with the Identity
Plot itself.
Then there are incarnations
of it that don't reflect on any
of those aesthetic issues,
don't reflect on the history of
the literary tradition,
don't engage questions about
language,
that deliver instead
conventional,
predictable satisfactions of
the genre, and these we would
call genre fiction.
And, if you recall,
Nabokov talks a little bit
about pornography as genre
fiction that gives you that
predictable mechanical
frisson of pleasure at
the predictable place,
and he describes Lolita
as rejecting the convention
of pornography.
You can think about his
description as applying also to
the Identity Plot,
that sometimes it functions,
and I think the Kingsolver
novel really is a good example
of this, where there are
predictable pleasures of the
child being enveloped by a
loving family after all the
complications of her identity,
finally it can all be resolved,
or there's a kind of pleasure
in that feeling that it could
never be resolved,
that tragic feeling.
So, there's genre fiction that
can end that way too.
So, other examples of genre
fiction: of course,
the detective novel is another.
My argument today is not to say
that this is the only convention
that our novels are working
with.
The detective genre is present
in Crying of Lot 49.
That's something that you
can think about productively
when you think about Oedipa's
search for knowledge and clues.
There is a way that Pynchon is
playing off that convention as
well.
To make the distinction is not
to reject one for the other,
so literary fiction and genre
fiction are both part of what
literary scholars use to make
especially these kinds of
broad-scale arguments.
So, it's not really enough,
if you want to argue about a
whole period of literary
history, to only skim off the
very most literary works.
Your argument doesn't have a
lot of historical purchase if
you do that.
If your ambition is to talk
about more narrowly the
evolution of an art form,
that's a very legitimate move
to make, to skim off just those
literary examples,
but if your ambition is to say
something through your
discussion of literature about
culture,
about politics,
about any other set of issues,
philosophical,
historical questions,
you want to be able to
demonstrate that the things
you're seeing in literary
fiction have a wider purchase
and have grabbed hold of the
imagination of a larger set of
people than the people who read
high literary novels.
So, you can make different
kinds of claims depending on
what combination of these kinds
of examples you use.
The Identity Plot obviously
has infinite variations.
I mentioned just a few to get
you thinking about them.
The character seems to be a
member of the majority group.
This is actually,
in one sense,
Franny and Zooey's case,
as you mentioned.
It seems like they are much
more in a majority.
They're white;
they are from an upper-class
section of New York;
they're distinguished by their
family's intellectualism.
Similarly, Ambrose could be
said to be in the majority
group, and certainly by the
definition of someone like
Morrison or Kingston,
that fiction--they're members
of a white Anglo-Saxon
Protestant heritage,
the members of Ambrose's
family.
But, if you recall,
in Ambrose His Mark the
family is eccentric.
They, too, are marked by their
difference from the churches in
town, the independence of their
thinking, the skill with which
they carve;
they have artistic skills.
The character does not seem to
be conflicted about his
membership in the minority
group.
This can happen.
Where do you get the drama,
then?
Well, sometimes you get the
drama from the efforts of the
majority group against that
piece.
Will that person betray their
group or not?
So, that's where the narrative
tension can come,
if you see this variation.
The character resists the whole
idea of having an identity
that's stable.
You might think of Kingston as
an example of this,
although I think you can argue
it both ways.
Certainly, she's not going to
think you can have an identity
that stays still.
All those self-revisions,
even just from that little
passage that I read about where
her story comes from,
that's a suggestion that she's
committed to an identity that's
changeable.
As this period moves on
towards the end of the twentieth
century, that variation is much
more common;
it gets more and more common.
The critique of identity in
theory, in the world of literary
theory--think of the work of
Judith Butler for example in the
late '80s and stretching into
the present--very influential on
undermining the idea that you
could have a stable identity at
all.
And that's where that term
"essentialism," identity
essentialism,
comes from.
That's a very negative idea by
now, by this point,
but in the 1970s,
and I would argue that in
Morrison's work,
you see still a commitment to
the idea that you can really be
in a peaceful way African
American,
and that that's a stable,
grounded identity,
or even that you can be white
as a stable,
grounded identity.
So, I think some writers
earlier in the period persist in
that idea, even while most have
gone to the sense that identity
is not stable.
There may be multiple
characters whose identities are
at stake in the novel,
and some subplots might end up
as tragedies,
some as comedy.
You can have a variation with
fiction based on fact.
We've seen that both in Richard
Wright, and now in Kingston.
It raises the stakes of the
fiction, and it suggests its
purchase on the real to write a
fiction that is sort of
autobiography,
based partly in fact or mostly
in fact.
It suggests that what's going
on in the fiction is actually
very close to what we live,
and that's a kind of claim for
fiction in and of itself.
And this is an example,
this last one:
Identity is not based on race
or ethnicity.
When we think about identity,
we usually think of race or
ethnicity but sometimes minority
status is going to be claimed or
identity is going to be claimed
on religious or philosophical
grounds or just on the grounds
of personality difference,
someone who's strange.
Salinger is sort of fond of
this.
Catcher in the Rye is an
example, I think,
of this, where Holden Caulfield
is at odds with his world
because he just sees things
really differently.
One of the kinds of claims that
you have to be prepared to make,
if you're making these broad
period-based claims,
is that your claim is specific
to your particular time period.
Now, you have to define your
time period.
I am dealing with post World
War II American literature,
somewhat arbitrary cutoff for
some scholars.
I think there are reasons to
think that it is a real cutoff,
having to do mostly with the
changes in the American cultural
mass market in the years after
World War II.
There are Identity Plots all
over in the history of
literature.
So, the plot of mistaken
identity is a staple of
Renaissance comedy.
Think of Midsummer Night's
Dream, for example.
Secret identity is a staple of
Gothic fiction.
This happens a lot in Dickens,
other kinds of Victorian
fiction.
Artistic identity.
Think of Portrait of the
Artist as a Young Man,
Joyce's novel about the
artistic formation of a person.
That's especially important to
Modernism.
And you could also say that
Woman Warrior is an
example of that version of
artistic self-creation.
Racial identity.
There is a wonderful book
called Our America by
Walter Benn Michaels.
He argues very persuasively
that there are whole ranges of
genre fiction in the 1920s that
are working out the logic of
race,
of a nativist logic of race in
the early twentieth century,
that these novels are governed
by that logic.
So, you have to be prepared to
explain how your feature is
different from other
incarnations in the history of
literature.
My contention is that the
Identity Plot,
as I am describing it,
becomes a preoccupation of both
literary and genre varieties of
writing in this period,
so that suggests its scope,
that it's not just the concern
of a few writers;
it's the concern of lots of
writers.
It's different in the degree of
its presence.
So, while Walter Benn Michaels
argues very persuasively for the
racial logic of popular
Westerns,
for example,
or for its relevance to Willa
Cather's work,
it doesn't sit at the center of
the plots of those novels in the
same way.
He can tease out the logic,
but it's not because that logic
is what the whole novel's drama
hangs on.
Some of the drama hangs on
that, but in the novels I am
talking about in this period,
it has risen to the level of
formula such that you can hang
the whole plot on that
structure,
and it's recognizable,
immediately recognizable.
So, that's what I mean when
I say in the next bullet point
that it achieves a kind of
solidity of formulaic structure.
And finally I want to argue,
as I have been doing in passing
in the last few lectures,
that these novels are working
very closely with things that
are happening in the culture in
general: so,
that tension between activism
and personal growth in the 1960s
as modes of social action,
the question about whether you
can intervene in politics
through culture,
is everywhere in the 1960s.
And you can see it come to a
head in the 1990s with the
culture wars,
when both liberals and
conservatives begin to fight
over,
especially over,
the syllabi of courses like
this.
So, if you think that it's
worth fighting a political fight
over the syllabus that we all
read, you are already committed
to a cultural politics.
So, the end point of this
is a very widespread argument in
the 1990s about where politics
happens,
and that argument revolves
around novels that feature the
Identity Plot 'cause those are
the kinds of novels that people
thought of as either advancing
or resisting the hegemony of a
white Western tradition that was
oppressive to minority people.
By the way, this final
incarnation of the Identity Plot
is going to be very important to
us when we read The Human
Stain.
That novel is deeply
embedded in that final iteration
of it.
How else do you know it's a
dominant convention?
Well, it has an end.
This is another way you can
locate its historical
specificity.
So, it has its limits,
and you can see it coming to
its end when you see more
elaborate embellishment and
variation on that formula,
that writers of ambition have
to push it further and further.
Even writers of the genre
fiction versions have to address
an audience looking for the
familiar pleasure,
but with just enough
difference.
You can think of those
Hollywood chase scenes.
They all look so much alike,
but the new ones always have to
have just that little bit more
interesting special effect,
or that much more dramatic car
flying off some high parapet.
Same thing with any narrative
formula.
And there comes a time when
writers of ambition simply
change the subject.
And I'm going to argue that
even though Roth is still
thinking in these terms,
the other novelists that we're
reading--starting next week and
into the end of the
semester--are beginning to
change the subject.
So one subject that comes up
very powerfully in those novels
is the subject of history.
It's not unrelated to identity,
but it is distinctly different.
And so, in Cormac McCarthy for
example, there is a palpable
engagement with history.
And in Edward P.
Jones, in a novel that really
seems like a classic outgrowth
of the Identity Plot novels,
especially of Toni Morrison,
is really much more about the
terror of history than it is
about the dramas of identity.
So, we will see how that
subject gets changed.
When we read the Woman
Warrior we might feel that
it is very, very conventional
because it does so much of what
I have just described that the
Identity Plot does.
I think, in a way,
that would be shortchanging it.
Some novels look dated or look
formulaic because they have been
incredibly successful,
and I think The Bluest Eye
and Woman Warrior are
examples of those kinds of
novels.
Woman Warrior,
and this is one of Frank
Chin's quarrels with it,
is widely, widely taught.
I always think hard about
including it on my syllabus.
Sometimes that's a reason to
include it on a syllabus,
as evidence in an ongoing,
unfolding argument;
sometimes it isn't.
In this case I have decided
pretty securely that it is;
it belongs here as a piece of
evidence in this unfolding
argument about what's happening
in the historical period.
Woman Warrior is widely
taught.
It is one of the foremost
examples of this kind of
identity writing.
It has some literary
satisfactions.
Some of those stories are
really compelling.
She's very good at limning a
character.
She's wonderful at reproducing
the dialog.
She reflects on the quality of
writing.
She is self-conscious about the
construction of her narrative.
And so, we can see an artist
telling the story of her own
coming to being as an artist in
the way she tells these stories.
There's all kinds of things you
can close read in here.
I'm going to run out of time.
Let me just show you one thing.
This is at the very end at 207.
This is when she is told the
story about her grandmother
taking the family to the opera,
and how bandits tend to rob the
houses that have been abandoned
while families are at the opera.
Instead, in this case,
the bandits attack the
audience.
In the experience the family's
all broken up in the attack:
By daybreak,
when my grandmother and mother
made their way home,
the entire family was home
safe,
proved to my grandmother that
our family was immune to harm as
long as they went to plays.
They went to many plays after
that.
The grandmother's logic is
completely twisted here.
It's turned upside down.
It doesn't make any sense.
They got attacked when they
went to the play,
so they go to plays in order to
stay safe because they happened
to survive that attack.
The reason why we're given that
logic is that this book is full
of stories about insanity.
And remember,
from the story about Moon
Orchid, insanity in this story
is defined as telling one story
over and over again,
insisting on the same story.
She becomes paranoid,
essentially a paranoid
schizophrenic.
That means that sanity,
healthiness,
is found in multiplicity,
illogic.
It's a kind of contradictory
claim about the status of sanity
and storytelling.
So, the illogic of this little
moment at the very end of the
book reaches back to all those
other examples of illogic and
insanity that we see throughout:
classic new critical technique
for building the meaning of a
certain trope across the
writing.
The other thing,
also, of course,
to think about,
is the fact that this takes
place around plays,
that it's art that's held out
as being the lucky thing.
It's art that's at the center,
and this of course,
especially the play,
reaches back to Maxine's
descriptions of her childhood
drawings where she painted page
after page after page of black,
worrying her teachers,
but for the young Maxine what
she saw in a black page was the
curtains of a theater ready to
open,
endless possibility.
So, it's that very appreciation
of the play, of the dramatic,
shared by the grandmother,
repeated even in this
inarticulate artistic creation
of the child that builds the
sense of artistic identity as an
inherited one.
So, I'm not going to go on with
this, but I just show you that
little passage and suggest some
of the ways that it's built up
over the course of the book to
show you that Kingston's novel
or autobiography--even though it
fulfills the convention so
completely that it looks like
genre fiction--if you locate it
in 1976 when it was first
published,
it's not at the end of a long
line of these;
it's at the beginning.
So, it is one of the first
popular books to bring together
Barth's insights with those of
the identity politics beginning
in the '60s.
So, Morrison and Kingston,
both, are some of the first to
take modernist
self-consciousness about writing
and combine it with this
interest in identity.
So, that's why I think it sort
of doesn't do her justice to see
this as genre fiction,
as too predictable,
because it was one of the early
versions of it.
So, next week we're going to
start reading
Housekeeping--just hold
on one sec--and I want you to
think about whether
Housekeeping fits the
Identity Plot model,
and, if it does,
how it does,
and if it doesn't,
how it doesn't.
That Identity Plot model was
very influential in its early
reception, so I want you to
think about how that worked.
Thank you.